what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm giving
you another
car chat um before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos
i'm really close to 17 000 subscribers
today so
if you guys want to help me hit it
that'd be super cool you know if not
just enjoy the content anyways okay guys
so
here's the deal i'm going to give you a
piece of dating advice that i would give
if i had a son
i know red pill discourages men from
taking dating advice from women i
i could see why you know um so you could
take this or leave it but this is just
what i would say if i had a brother or a
son
um i do have brother but they get girls
easily so it's not even a problem but
anyways
do not spend
more than ten dollars on a first date
with a girl
and i would even encourage you you could
spend zero dollars
and let me tell you why if a girl is
going to turn you down because you asked
her to coffee
if a girl is going to turn you down
because you asked her to go for a walk
if your girl is going to turn you down
because you asked her to chipotle
she's not in it for the right reason
she's not trying to get to know you
she just wants your resources your
attention or your validation
if you want a girl that's actually
looking for a husband
or is actually attracted to you and into
you
it she you're not gonna be be able
to buy your way into that do you think
if drake
asked her on for on a date to go for a
walk
for a drink she would say no of course
not
of course not and that's why my two my
my two cents
is to spend ten dollars or less
on a girl on a first date
um if you want to split it that's cool i
think um just from a girls perspective
this is why um in the past i was super
against splitting and it had nothing
nothing to do with the money um
my parents like
they do pretty well like i've never
really had a problem taking care of
myself
or money like money wise if i really
needed money i would go to my parents
um but i always took it like a guy
wasn't
interested in me if he wanted to split
on a first date because i felt like if a
model came in or a super pretty girl
came
in he would 100 cover that and if he
wasn't gonna split it
um that he just wasn't interested it was
never anything about the money um
now that i've learned a little bit more
about like the guy's perspective and how
they tend to feel
used and just like um
taken advantage of a lot of the times i
don't think i would be
as nitpicky about that now
but yeah i don't know just my two cents
um
just my two cents from what i've seen
and what i continue to see
so let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or you disagree don't forget
to subscribe to the channel i'm so close
to 17
000. if you guys want to hit that
subscribe button to help me get there
today that would be great
and i will talk to you guys next time